Okay.
Hello everyone.
Apologies for the delay.
I hope this is all working.
Um,
I'm taking questions from Patriot on
people today.
So
there's 841 questions ready to go.
So hopefully I'm up to this.
What should teaching and research in the
humanities look like?
I'm going to Grad School for literature
and I don't want my work to serve
ideological possession.
Well,
the thing is,
first of all is that you kind of have to
educate yourself when you go to graduate
school,
you know you have your courses,
but I don't think that you learn more
than about 10% of what graduate school
can teach you by taking the courses you
have to read.
And the mistake that most people read is
make is that they only read what's been
published in the last five or six years
in their own narrow field.
And that's increasingly a bad idea.
Um,
the libraries are full of classic books
and I would say take your field,
go back to the beginning of the field.
At least read the people who wrote the
classic works.
Bring yourself up to date and then
familiarize yourself with as much
history,
as much history of art,
as much history of literature and
literature as you can possibly manage.
You want to learn as much as you can
about everything.
I would also say you have to ally that
with a certain degree of specialization.
You have to pick one topic and really
become expert at it,
but it'll serve as a doorway to,
because everything's connected.
It'll serve as a doorway to what's
behind it,
so you focus on one thing and read as
much as you can on that.
That's your specific discipline.
Then outside of that,
read as widely as you possibly could
manage.
The other thing I would really
recommend,
and this is also true if you're going to
university,
is it isn't enough to read.
You also have to write and if you're
going to go to graduate school,
you should write every day.
It's a good idea for anyone who wants to
develop themselves intellectually,
but even half an hour a day,
you know,
that's 180 hours a year.
That's a lot of thinking because writing
is thinking and you should be writing
out your understanding of what you wrote
or what you read and the questions you
have about it and trying to formulate
what you regard as clear questions and
problems and also clear answers.
Uh,
both of those.
And that's how I would say you should
approach graduate school.
Okay.
Have you thought about slowing down
there?
Are people worried about how hard you're
pushing yourself with the countless
commitments?
Yes.
Well,
I would say that those people worried
about that include,
ah,
I dunno if it's me,
but certainly my family,
they're worried about it.
But I'm putting competent people around
me increasingly to handle the scheduling
of the public events for example.
And I have good agents in a good
publisher and,
um,
I'm learning how to manage this.
I think I've,
I'm not really interested,
I suppose in slowing down,
although it has been a bit much in the
last year and a half.
I,
I'm,
I do better in some ways when I'm
working flat out.
Uh,
if my health was good,
it's better than it was by a large
margin.
And maybe it's still getting better.
If my health was good,
this,
none of this would be an overwhelming
challenge,
but I'm trying to do everything I can to
put my health in order and many,
many things have been fixed.
So yeah,
I thought about slowing down,
but I've decided against it I guess is
really the final answer to that.
That's the other thing.
You know there are times in your life
where it's not time to slow down,
it's time to
become more efficient.
That's the thing.
You can become so efficient,
you know,
you end up doing things in five minutes
that would otherwise take you a week
might.
That might seem like an exaggeration,
but,
and I suppose it is to some degree,
but it's not that much of an
exaggeration.
So as you take on more responsibilities
and you determine that you're going to
become more efficient,
the responsibility pushes the
efficiency.
So
what do they say too?
There's time enough to sleep when you're
in the grave.
Many who respect your work feel your
tweets are often impulsive or even
expedient.
Very funny.
In certain interactions,
would you consider a change in the way
you tweet?
Well,
I've been considering that for a very
long time.
One of the things I did in the last
month,
which that I think was productive.
Twitter's a hard,
hard medium to manage because it rewards
impulsivity and I have somewhat of a
temper and I suspect that it's maybe I'm
more susceptible to being,
um,
to being tempted to respond in a
yeah,
too forceful manner.
Maybe I'm more tempted by that than I
should be.
Um,
but twitter is real useful.
I mean it does keep me updated with
regards to the,
the ongoing,
let's say,
war that's raging at the bottom of our
culture and it doesn't enable me to stay
in contact with people,
at least to some degree.
And it's a great way of communicating,
um,
small,
but at least in principle important
ideas.
And also to let people know about what
I'm doing on youtube and with the tours
and,
and all of that.
People seem to
respond positively to those sorts of
notifications.
So what I did do in the last month was
to find people.
I tweeted out one day,
I asked people to send me the twitter
handles of organizations or individuals
who were reporting on positive
developments in a credible and realistic
way.
Human progress.org seems to be doing
that really well.
I thought it would be good to tilt my
twitter feed toward or my twitter,
uh,
my actions towards things that are
positive and also true as much as
possible.
And so I've started doing that in the
last month.
Um,
I feel somewhat of an obligation to,
if I'm being discussed publicly by
journalists or,
or other professors and they
misrepresent me or misrepresent the
ideas that they're purporting to
discuss,
then I feel like I have a moral
obligation to,
I suppose one is to defend myself I
suppose and certainly to object to the
miss utilization of ideas by my fellow
academics.
I don't know if that's a,
I don't know if that's reasonable or
not.
It's not easy to figure out in a
situation like this,
how much you shut up,
how much you stay patient,
how much you push back,
how much you fight,
how,
how firmly you respond,
whether or not to use wet
mean the rule.
I tried to outline in a,
in my book
12 rules for life.
There's a chapter called
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
And there's a philosophy of discipline
in there and it really has two
dimensions,
let's say,
or two.
It's,
it's at the juncture of two ideas.
One idea is that you don't want to make
any more rules that necessary because
you get tangled up in them.
So minimum necessary rule.
So that's a good guideline for setting
up any structure even in dealing with
yourself.
And then if you're going to have rules
you have to them because otherwise
they're not rules.
And so how do you enforce them with
minimal necessary force and some of that
has to be played with,
you know,
and experimented with.
So you know what minimal force is.
Those are really good principles and I
try to govern myself by them in my
twitter behavior.
But,
and I hope that that successful,
um,
you know,
sometimes when I've gone after people I
went to after a couple of journalists in
Canada last year who
wrote I would,
what I would regard as scurrilous and
incompetent articles.
That's a bad combination.
And
you know,
it was kind of a harsh exchange I would
say,
but it isn't clear that it was the wrong
thing to do.
So
it's hard to know how much you have to
skirt the ragged edge of disaster if you
want to do things right.
So anyways,
I am changing the way I tweet because
I'm trying to make it the bulk of it
informative and positive.
I guess I should say something about
that too.
You know,
there's a lot of really good things
going on in the world.
So we have poverty,
absolute poverty between the year 2000
and 2012 which was three years ahead of
what the UN had hoped would happen.
You know,
and cynics say,
well you have absolute poverty,
but the cutoff was kind of arbitrary.
It was a dollar 90 a day,
if I remember correctly,
which obviously is quite low.
Um,
so it's not a real transformation.
It's like it's a real transformation.
Some number had to be picked to
represent that absolute poverty.
And I don't suspect the UN erred on the
side of capitalist over optimism.
Perhaps they did.
Hundreds of thousands of people are
being connected to the power grid every
day.
Fresh water's available,
not to fewer and fewer people,
but to more and more people.
And that's happening extremely rapid,
rapidly.
No starvation in India and China is a
thing completely of the past.
You never hear about that.
And that's pretty much the case for the
rest of the world except now.
And then for political reasons.
So,
you know,
everybody's got a cell phone or an oil
on anybody who doesn't,
is going to have one in the next 10
years.
And that puts in people's hands,
uh,
a degree of communication and access
that would have been absolutely
incomprehensible even 15 years ago.
So
it seems to me that the reason too that
I changed,
it seemed to me that it was worthwhile
to change the way that I was using
twitter because all these good things
are happening
and just concentrating on this
polarization process that seems to have
gripped us in the West seems
counterproductive given all those good
things that are going on in the
background.
Now that doesn't make what's going on in
the west with regards to political
polarization,
trivial,
but it does set it inside a much more
positive context.
So that's something to keep in mind.
What if a client's need for autonomy
slash identity in therapy,
they would prefer that which is
meaningful and therefore under the under
their control.
Is this not unhealthy?
I'm not exactly sure how to meet what to
make of that question.
Well first of all,
let's try.
What if a client's need for autonomy,
identity in therapy?
That's paramount mean again in my book
and in Chapter Nine assume the person
that you're listening to know something
you don't have so that you can learn
something.
Maybe because you need to learn
Cause like,
what do you know in therapy,
I don't think that if you're a good
therapist,
you try to take responsibility for the
decisions that your clients make.
Like you don't take that decision making
onto yourself because you have to adopt
a position of radical ignorance.
No,
a person is sitting across from you.
And this is the true,
true of every person.
You know a person is sitting across from
you and they don't understand
themselves,
but you really don't understand them.
And if you're a therapist or maybe even
if you're a friend or a partner for that
matter,
the person wants help and so something's
wrong as far as they're concerned and
there might be some way to fix it.
And that's your initial starting place.
I would say both of you have to kind of
agree on that in a psychotherapeutic
situation.
Well,
but you don't know what's wrong.
You know,
you know something's wrong because the
person is upset enough to come and seek
counseling.
So they want to set their life right.
But you have no idea what's wrong.
You don't know anything about the way
they think or what,
what they value or what their past is
or,
or how,
or what they're,
what they're like physiologically or
what their temperament is like are,
or what,
how things are going in their
relationships are,
what their career is like.
You just,
the things you don't know about that
person,
man,
it's,
it's intersectionality gone mad.
I can tell you that.
And so you got to listen and let the
person tell you what it is that's wrong
as if you don't know,
cause you don't know.
And,
and so,
and you have to ask questions of
clarification and,
but you always have to remember,
not only do you not know what's wrong,
maybe the person doesn't know what's
wrong.
It's highly probable.
They know that something's wrong,
but they don't know exactly what.
And they certainly don't know what
caused it.
And so you gotta listen radically and
clarify now ask questions and make sure
you're not confused so that you do
understand.
And maybe you can help the person start
to understand what they're talking
about.
Um,
or thinking about,
cause talking in thinking are very much
the same thing.
And then then well maybe you get some
sense of what's wrong and maybe some
sense of how it came about.
God only knows how long that'll take.
And then the next thing you have to
figure out is,
well,
what would a solution look like?
Like even hypothetically,
what does the person want?
And do they know what they want?
And if they don't know what they want,
then how can you help them figure out
what they want and how do you help them
figure out what they need and how do you
help them admit to that and all of that.
And so that's a boat load of listening
there.
Again,
you know,
and it's the same in every relationship
that you have.
If you're trying to foster that person's
development,
he want to find out,
well what's wrong in their lives?
And,
but they have to figure that out because
they're the ones that,
they're the ones that will have to bear
the responsibility for the decisions.
So you don't want to take that on to
yourself.
It's like,
well,
I don't want to tell you what to do
because I don't know what you should do.
Like we can both agree that you should
move toward what's better for you and
hopefully for the people around you.
Cause we would include that in the
definition of better,
right?
Because otherwise it's not sustainable.
But we have to talk forever to find out
what that is.
And you have to be,
you have to be very incautious to think
that you can
make decisions for someone.
It's an arrogant move and it's an ill
advised move and you shouldn't do it if
you're properly terrified of your errors
because,
well,
again,
I'll repeat.
You're not the one that's going to have
to take responsibility for the decisions
they are.
So it has to be left in their hands.
And so,
so autonomy,
it's everything in a clinical practice.
No,
that doesn't mean that you can't help a
person strategize.
You know,
you might say,
well as you're moving towards some
formulation of the problem,
you might say,
well here's five things that it might
be,
or here's the list of things that might
be bothering you.
Or you know,
you can make suggestions but they can't
be baited suggestions either.
You can't overweight the one you hope
they'll choose.
You know,
again,
it's,
it's in cautious.
A lot of this I would say I learned well
from thinking about it,
but also from reading Carl Rogers,
I'd really recommend Carl Rogers.
You know,
he,
he was a smart guy when it came to
listening.
You can really learn a lot from,
and he was also smart in how we are
outlined,
the client's need for autonomous
development and that's the development
of the individual.
So
any update on your plans to start
providing independent classes or an
online university?
Well,
I'm working with some young people right
now who are very,
very smart.
And the first thing we're,
we're going to build modules by the
looks of things.
Each module,
hopefully it will stand alone because
then we can test them instead of
launching like a whole university.
Which seems to be a crazy thing to do.
We're going to make independent modules
for different purposes and then launch
them probably as quiet,
shy,
independent.
Yeah.
Products let's say to see if there's a
demand for them.
So the one we're working right now on
right now,
and I'm not going to say too much about
it,
is a competitive writing module where
you'll be able to look at paragraphs and
okay.
Paragraphs that other people have
written.
Okay.
Of a variety of sorts.
No,
I don't think I'll tell you about that.
I bet her weight.
So anyways,
we're going to write a competitive
writing module and because one of the
big problems,
the biggest problems that has to be
solved for any online university is how
do you teach people to write,
because you don't want the university
just to be lectures and multiple choice
tests.
Even though that could be done with some
degree of reasonable competence.
Mostly what you want when you educate
people as to educate them,
not so much into like factual knowledge
but intellectual skill.
They have to be able to speak.
So we'll need a speaking module and they
have to be able to think and we'll have
to develop exercises that are relevant
to critical thinking.
Writing is a big part of that.
Um,
so
yeah,
and they have to be able to read.
And so those are the big problems to
solve.
And then the other problem for an online
university is creditation.
Obviously we've got some ideas about
that.
And also what you do with regards to the
social element,
because that's a huge part of
university,
is to develop an intellectual peer
group.
Right?
That's really an important part in yet.
It's not going to be easy to replace
that online.
You know,
the relationships that people make in
college often last while they can last
for decades or maybe they can last a
lifetime for that matter.
But
yeah,
it's a place where you catalyze your
adult identity and the peers that you
pick are a big part of that.
Um,
of course some of the peers that you
pick when you go to university should be
the great people of the past.
Um,
yeah,
that's really what university is for,
is to make them in some sense your peers
know that,
you know,
that's pushing it because you'll have to
do a lot of work before they become
peers.
Anyways,
we're definitely working on this.
Um,
the part of the problem is,
is that I'm,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's what's the problem?
MMM.
Okay.
I'm doing enough other things at the
moment so that finding the time to do
this credibly in addition is one of the
major challenges.
So,
hmm.
I married young and have had only one
sexual partner.
Now I desire a variety but value of my
marriage and will not cheat any insight
and overcoming this conflict.
As a matter of fact.
Yes.
I would say get the variety with your
partner.
You know,
there's lots of
games you can play to spice up your
sexual life,
you know,
um,
by some lingerie,
like buy a hundred pieces,
you know,
buy something sexy for your partner to
where maybe multiple things,
um,
by some,
by whatever you need that you might want
to experiment with.
You know,
I mean you have to introduce that spirit
of pretend play that you had when you
were a little kid into your sexual life.
And then you have many partners in the
same person
and
you put some thought into it.
You know,
I mean sex is something that,
that sex is a domain in which expertise
can be developed just like any other
domain.
And some of that's play and fantasy play
and all of that and some of it's sexual
technique and,
and I guess then the other thing I would
say is take stock of each other and see
if there are things that you could do in
your life that would make you more
attractive to one another.
You know,
those are hard questions because no one
wants to say,
well,
you know,
I'd be more attracted to my wife
sexually if she just acted x way.
And the same with regards to how a
wife's contemplation of her husband.
But those are the real questions,
man.
It's like if your partner isn't acting
in a manner that is sexually attractive
than either there's something wrong with
you or there's something wrong with
them.
And of course I know people have ill
health and all of that.
I'm not talking about that.
But those harsh judgements that your
sexual attraction makes are also very
useful ways of orienting yourself
towards proper behavior in the world.
So I would say
any insight and overcoming this
conflict.
Now I desire variety,
but I value my marriage and will not
cheat.
Well,
admit to the variety that you want and
see to what degree you can fulfill that
within the confines of the marriage.
It's also part of coming into contact
with the shadow.
I would say if you want to look at it
from a union perspective,
you might have all sorts of sexual
desires that are,
that part of you feels should remain
taboo and maybe they should.
I'm not suggesting ag absolute,
sexually libertine behavior and then
with sexuality has to be regulated very
carefully,
but
you might be able to push yourself with
some time and effort and contemplation
and some admission of fantasy.
And all of that into domains of sexual
satisfaction that you haven't achieved
before.
Why do I know what to discuss?
Religious fundamentalism more often and
more in depth.
Many people consider you a religious
apologist as a consequence.
Well,
it's okay if people considered me a
religious apologist.
I am a religious apologist.
So an apologist is someone who makes an
argument for something.
And I'm constantly making arguments for
a religious perspective on life or
religious orientation towards life.
Uh,
an orientation that's centered in,
in meaning and orientation that's
centered in desire for all things to
thrive in so far as that's possible.
Desire for people to speak the truth and
act out the truth and act
responsibility,
act responsibly and all of that.
And I think that there's something,
something transcendently necessary about
all of that.
And I think it is the antidote to hell.
So that,
that makes me a religious apologists.
The fundamentalists,
I dunno.
Which fundamentalists you mean if you
mean the Christian fundamentalists?
Well,
I understand where they're coming from.
You know,
I think the Christian
Christianity is an ethical framework
above all else.
And it's predicated in a story about the
way the world is constituted and,
and the story provides the foundation
for that ethic and the ethic unites the
community and gives people direction.
This is a big deal.
Now,
if the story is challenged,
if the foundational stories challenged,
which is certainly what happened as a
consequence of the rise of empirical
science,
then the foundation for the ethic starts
to,
starts to shake and tremble.
And that threatens the ethic.
But the ethic is what holds people
together and gives them direction.
So you can't just lose the ethic.
So the fundamentalist Christians are all
short circuited because they know that
there's something to the ethic and they
understand that the foundation has been
shaken,
but they don't know what to do about it.
So they insist that the foundation has
not been shaken.
And I that,
so I think the way out of that is to
understand that
the truth that govern ethics and the
truth that govern the description of the
world as a material place are not the
same.
They're not,
they're not,
they're not of the same kind.
Um,
how they're related.
I'm not exactly sure,
but there's no simple one to one
relationships.
You can't describe the world and then
immediately extract out in ethic.
It's partly because there are just too
many ways of describing the world.
So this is the,
that the fundamental point of difference
as far as I can tell between Sam Harris
and I and hopefully what we'll discuss
in the summer.
So,
so that's the Christian fundamentalists
and I don't really see that there are a
particularly threatening group as far as
I can tell.
I mean there are certainly not in the
ascendance by any stretch of the
imagination.
Um,
they're not involved in any particularly
reprehensible political behavior unless
you count conservatism.
And it is by no means obvious that
they're even holding their ground in the
culture war.
So I'm not very worried about them.
Um,
Islamic fundamentalism,
that's a whole different story.
But I don't know enough about it to
discuss it intelligently.
I don't understand Islam.
It,
it,
I'm concerned about.
It's,
what would you call compatibility with,
with the Democratic West.
Okay.
It isn't obvious to me that there are
medium to high functioning Muslim
democracies.
I suppose turkeys the closest one,
but Turkey's pretty soon,
pretty shaky at the moment.
I think that the failure to separate
church and state,
or even if we don't call it a failure,
the fact that church and state hasn't
been technically separated in Islam
makes it difficult to understand how
it's possible for Islam and modern
western democratic traditions to
coexist.
I don't know how that can be,
that gap can be bridged.
Um,
you could say,
well with goodwill and let's,
let's hope that's the case.
Um,
that doesn't mean I don't think that
Muslims can live in a modern western
democracy.
I mean there are many,
many kinds of Muslims just like there
are many kinds of Jews and Christians.
And so,
and then there's the problem of the
current proclivity of the extreme end of
the Muslim fundamentalists world to
become,
to be very violent in very many ways.
And so,
you know what,
I'm not a great admirer of the Saudis to
say the least.
I don't appreciate their brand of,
of Wahhabi Islam.
And I don't appreciate their exports of
that view with their petro dollars to
the rest of the world.
So
I guess that's what I have to say about
fundamentalists.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I've been trying to listen to my
conscience,
but I can't tell the difference between
fear,
willful blindness or genuine conscience.
Well,
the first thing I would say about that
is it is quite clear that you are in
fact trying to listen to your conscience
because that's probably the first thing
that you discover.
So that's a really good question.
Okay,
fear.
Well,
here's the test and you don't want to do
this stupidly.
If you think that you should do
something and you think that the reason
you might not be doing it is because
you're afraid,
then you should do it.
So that way you can find out if it's
fear.
You know?
I think your question is,
well,
how do I know my conscience isn't just
masquerading as fear of saying,
well,
you shouldn't do that,
but it's rationalizing the real issue,
which is you're afraid of doing that.
Now see,
here's a reason that you want to tell
the truth.
And I parked,
I kind of figured this out when I was
looking deeply into the Pinocchio Story.
You know,
in Pinocchio as Pinocchio strives to
become real,
he,
he has a conscience to guide him,
but it's jimminy cricket,
this insect.
But Jimmy hasn't really a very good
conscience.
He's a bit dogmatic to begin with.
Dogmatic and inexperienced.
And so it's,
it's not like the conscience is an
unerring guide.
It's like a partner in discovery.
And as you move forward in your life and
you consult your conscience and you
listened to it,
then it gets smarter and so to you.
But there's a code of their,
and this is why I've suggested part of
the reason why I've suggested so
frequently in my lectures and in my book
that people try not to lie.
You see,
there are many systems,
you have many systems within,
let's say,
that guide you.
And one of those is your capacity for
rational thought.
And then you have a variety of emotional
systems and motivational systems and
internal dramas and intuitions and
bodily sensations like lots and lots of
and senses,
lots of systems that are guiding you.
And many of them operate,
you might say,
unconsciously,
autonomously,
instinctively,
implicitly,
all of that.
Now you pr nonetheless,
you program them like you feed them
content,
let's say just like you feed your body
nourishment,
you feed them and a lot of the content
that you feed them pertains directly to
your voluntary thoughts and speech and
your actions.
And then if you pathologize those by
lying.
So if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to,
which is more common.
And if you act in ways that you consider
that act in ways you considered
reprehensible,
then you pathologize all of those
autonomous systems that guide you.
It's like you're programming them badly.
You're building an AI system inside
yourself really in,
in,
in some sense that is what you're doing
that has very bad,
it's very bad training data.
And so the output it produces will be
well,
won't guide you properly.
And so you don't want to pathologize
your guidance systems.
It's a really bad idea.
So that's why you have to not lie.
And maybe that's also why you have to
say what you have to say.
And you have to say it clearly as well.
And you have to learn how to do that.
So that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out.
And then you have to have a dialogue
with your conscience.
And you might ask,
it's like,
okay,
well what should I do?
Or what should,
should I do this or should I not do
this?
So let's say you're thinking,
should I not do this?
In the case of a temptation,
maybe you have a chance to develop a new
relationship.
You know,
and you're,
you're excited about it and apprehensive
about it and afraid of it and you don't
know how to sort out all those feelings.
And the first thing is you really have
to want to sort them out.
That's why you have to orient yourself
to something that's a genuine up.
You know that the star above the
horizon,
you have to really want things to be
straight and you have to have thought
that through.
And you have to know what it means for
things not to be straight.
And really what it means is that you're
headed for hell in one way or another.
And if you understand that it's enough,
maybe it's enough to scare you straight.
You really got to think that through.
Then you've got to think about how much
better it would be if you aimed up and,
and that really has to kind of permeate
your whole being.
And so then you're oriented that way.
You're oriented to dop and you're
deciding that it's okay to try to tell
the truth and then you can start to rely
on this dialogue with your conscience.
But both of you have to learn and you're
going to make mistakes along the way.
You know,
that's okay.
You can say,
well,
I'm going to try this without being
certain that it's right.
You can even say,
I'm going to say this without being
certain that it's correct.
Like if you're arguing with your wife or
your husband or your,
or your sister,
your father,
and you have an idea about what might be
going on,
you can say,
look,
here's my idea about what's going on.
Um,
who knows what that idea might be
contaminated with like maybe I'm putting
it forward just because I'm too proud or
arrogant or angry or fearful or
whatever.
That's possible.
Let's see if we can figure that out.
But you can offer tentatively and both
have added.
That's what you do if it's a hypothesis,
right?
You both have at it and see if it's an
idea that's worthy of,
of keeping you do that with your
conscience and then you were move
forward.
There's a,
there's a technique and behavioral
psychology called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism.
So let's say that we,
you and I have been sitting down and we
decided that you're going to try
something new this week.
Like maybe your agoraphobic and you're
having a hard time in a parking lot.
And so getting out of the car and going
to the grocery store.
So maybe we say,
well you to drive to the grocery store
and you're just going to walk halfway to
the
halfway from your car to the door and
that's good enough for like do that
every second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it.
So that's collaborative empiricism,
you're running a little experiments,
you think,
well your conscience is guiding you
towards something.
You take a tentative step in that
direction and then you check and see,
well,
you know,
did what I wanted to have happen or
occur as an outcome.
That's the crucial question.
And that's the crucial question for
behavioral truth,
right?
That's the pragmatic perspective.
Did what I want to have happened happen
as a consequence of my framework of
interpretation and my action.
If the answer is yes,
then I have not invalidated it.
Right?
That's,
that's the pragmatic philosophy in a
nutshell.
And it's,
it's very,
very smart.
So you have a dialogue with your
conscience that never ends and hopefully
it gets wiser and you get wiser.
And
that's the dialogue that young talked
about between the conscious and the
unconscious,
between your,
your fantasy life,
say the life that sort of underneath you
as a conscious being,
like the life that's part of your
biological platform,
the biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness.
If a dialogue with that.
We're always in dialogue,
we're always in dialogue,
right,
with everything.
So
pursue that.
I've watched many hours of your videos,
but I don't think I've ever heard you
describe yourself on the big five model.
Could care to tell us how you rank on
each trade.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well there's a problem because I know
the tests and so it's hard for me to
take them without being
well because I know the tasks,
right?
So it's hard for me to take them without
the ever present threat of conscious
manipulation.
Um,
I've gone through them with my family,
you know,
to,
to see if we get a more accurate,
uh,
accurate judgment.
So I can tell you on the big 10 scale,
which is the understand myself
personality scale,
I'm pretty,
I think it's 75th 80th percentile,
something like that.
Um,
99th percentile for assertiveness.
So I'm pretty extroverted cause those
two together make extroversion.
And then with neuroticism,
that's a hard one because I've had this
problem with chronic depression that
looks like it's auto immune related.
And so I felt a lot more negative
emotion then the typical person does.
I would say by a substantial margin,
um,
withdrawal,
well,
I don't seem to shy away from things.
So,
you know,
apart from the fact that I do feel
anticipatory anxiety,
which I think is secondary to this
depression,
let's say,
I don't seem to shy away from things.
So I don't think that temperamentally,
I'm particularly high and withdrawal,
I am more,
um,
it's not irritable.
What's the,
what's the next one?
Volatile.
I'm higher in volatility than withdrawal
by a substantial margin.
I can be quite irritable,
but again,
it's hard to dissociate that from the
depression.
So anyways,
my levels of negative emotion are higher
than I would prefer.
Um,
agreeableness,
I'm pretty compassionate,
pretty high,
and compassion's like 75 80th
percentile.
So,
um,
you know,
and,
but I'm,
I'm relatively low in politeness,
so I think but not,
you know,
not fifth percentile,
something like 30th percentile,
40% off I remember correctly.
So,
um,
that means that,
huh?
It means that I'm blunt enough to hurt
people's feelings now and then,
and that I really don't like that
because the compassion thing gets me.
So,
um,
conscientiousness,
I'm moderately orderly,
70,
75th percentile and 99th percentile for
industriousness and then openness,
both of them intellect and 99th
percentile for intellect.
And then it's like 95th,
something like that for openness or
higher.
Um,
so that's where I,
that's where I rank.
So
my wife and I found out earlier in the
year and we may not be able to have
children.
Then last month I was diagnosed with
cancer.
Man,
how do I combat depression?
While the first thing that we should
point out here,
I'm very sorry to hear about all that.
That's,
that's a lot of tragedy in a very short
period of time.
And,
um,
and I'm not going to give you any casual
advice because,
but I,
maybe I can make some things clearer.
The first is you're not depressed.
You've had terrible things happen to
you.
That's not the same thing,
right?
I distinguished between them.
If a client comes to me and they say
they're feeling very sad and down and
anxious and worried about everything and
so forth,
then I kind of walked through their
life.
Do they have friends?
Do they have a family?
Do they have a meaningful job?
Is their educational background
appropriate for their level of
intelligence and ability?
Are they taking care of themselves?
Do they have something to look forward
to?
Do they use their time outside of work
productively and wisely,
et cetera.
So you think about those as the
dimensions of a good life.
There's more,
or maybe there's fewer,
but that's not too bad for a quick and
dirty first pass through,
let's say.
Um,
those are the dimensions by the way,
that you work on.
If you do the future authoring program
in the self authoring suite,
you're asked to think about all those
dimensions and consider what your life
might be like if you optimized along all
of them.
And so,
um,
if you,
if all of those things are going well
for you and you feel terrible all the
time,
then you're depressed.
Cause there's,
there's something wrong with your
emotional regulation.
You know,
I mean,
maybe you're having an existential
crisis that's a possibility,
but I mean,
let's assume we can't see anything
structurally wrong with your life,
but you're feeling terrible.
Then I would say,
well,
you have depression.
There's something wrong.
Maybe it's physiological and people like
that.
In my experience,
those are the people who often really
benefit from antidepressants.
But then there's other sort of person
who,
who is in trouble.
You know,
they,
their educational attainment is not what
it should be.
They don't have a job.
They have an alcohol or drug problem.
They have a family that's really not
functioning well or they don't have a
family.
Their immediate relationship,
intimate relationship is nonexistent or
terrible.
Um,
their friends are nonexistent.
Or,
or,
or worthless and,
and destructive.
Um,
they don't get along with their
relatives there in poor mental and
physical health.
You get the picture that's,
and they're not feeling good.
There are moods low and they're anxious.
That's not depression.
Like it might be,
you know,
but it's a terror.
But what that is,
is a terrible life and those are
different things they needed to be.
They need to be conceptualized
differently.
Now even if you have a terrible life and
antidepressant might be able to lift you
up enough so that you can keep fighting,
let's say,
assuming that that's what you're doing,
but an antidepressant obviously isn't
going to help,
isn't going to remove the fact of your
terrible life.
Now you,
you've got terrible things happening to
you at the moment and,
and there's no simple answer to that.
I would say you could,
you could take a look at chapter 12 in
my book,
12 rules for life.
It's,
it's called a pet.
A cat.
When you encounter one on the street.
And in part it's a,
it's an autobiography I autobiographical
chapter about how my wife and I and my
family,
my,
my son and daughter and my,
my extended family as well dealt with my
daughter's extremely serious illness
while she,
it's still,
it's still plagues are to some degree,
although not nearly as much as it did.
She was very seriously ill when she was
a teenager and a,
it was an ongoing crisis,
a continual for years of crisis.
And so the question is how do you cope
with that?
And the answer is,
the first answer is you shrink your
timeframe.
You know,
you've had these,
especially with regards to your
diagnosis.
So like
all of a sudden your future has been
thrown completely into chaos and
you don't know how to deal with that.
And who would you do what you can to
stabilize your medical treatment and do
optimize your quality of life while
that's happening.
Very complicated thing to do.
And then I would say you live for the
day,
you know,
for the week maybe,
maybe a week's too much even,
but for the day it's like you get up in
the morning,
you think I need to do everything I can
to make this day as meaningful and and
rich as I possibly can.
And hopefully I will have had a full day
by this evening and then I'll be able to
sleep and then I'll be able to get up in
the morning and say,
I'm going to try to make this day as
useful and meaningful and engaging as it
can be.
And then maybe when you're really sick,
you don't have a day,
you have hours and then you do the same
thing for the hours.
And then maybe you do the same thing
with the minutes.
I would also say,
you know,
you've been through a lot of shock and
it's conceivable that you might need to
talk to someone.
It's also conceivable that an
antidepressant could help you,
you know,
you've got a lot to deal with and you
might need your nervous system might
need some stabilization with all that
stress.
And so that's something to consider.
Antidepressants are also quite effective
as pain medications,
especially a drug called Cymbalta.
So that's also worth knowing because you
need to know about effective pain
medication.
It's very important,
um,
in extreme situations of pain.
Opiates of course are the drug of
choice,
but you can use drugs like
methylphenidate that riddle in the Adhd
drug,
you can use them as adjuncts to,
to pain medication.
And people need to know that because
the,
um,
there basically amphetamines,
amphetamines have analgesic properties,
but they also keep,
they also maintain alertness.
And so the problem with opiates is they
can be sedating but an opiate
amphetamine combination.
And this is for people who are in
absolutely intractable pain by the,
um,
that can increase alertness and help
cope with pain.
And it's really useful to know what you
might need to cope with pain.
So I would say shrink your time horizon
and then,
oh,
thank you.
Okay,
thanks Tim.
Shrink your time horizon and then
concentrate on the
concentrate on the moment.
Whatever that moment happens to be.
Might be the next minute.
You know,
I don't know what else to do when you're
in an extreme situation.
The other thing,
I guess the final thing I would say with
regards to the,
we may not be able to have children.
Well you need a plan to address that to
the best that that you can to the best
way that you can.
And then you have to give yourself some
time to reconceptualize your life and
your future.
And I would say news,
like we may not be able to have children
that probably takes about a year or year
and a half to digest.
So don't be too hard on yourself if you
haven't figured it out yet.
It's any major life transformation,
like a really major life transformation.
I would say it takes a minimum of a year
to really adapt to
please give your perspective on why
polyamory is bad for the individual and
society.
Well,
I think the fundamental reason is
there's a bunch of reasons.
I mean the first is society seem to
function better.
That is less violently,
let's say when there's one woman per
man.
If there's many women per man,
there aren't many women for every man.
There are a handful of men,
let's say a minority of men,
a predo distribution of men
who have a disproportionate number of
women and a lot of men who have none and
those aren't happy man,
let's put it that way.
Uh,
there are men who are very likely to get
up to no good,
very rapidly.
So there's that.
Then I would say the women who,
let's say a man has many women,
and let's say he's a desirable man for
that matter,
just for the sake of argument,
if he has a variety of women,
those women don't have much of him,
so they don't get to establish a real
individual relationship with him because
it's going to be fragmentary.
And I don't believe that that's
satisfying for people.
I think that what you want as much as
you possibly can is to have people
around you with whom you can weave your
life together over the short term,
medium term and long term.
It adds depth to your life in a way that
almost nothing else can.
And so
what you do,
and so I'd been speaking more about
permanent polyamorous relationships you
might ask,
but what about sequential ones where you
know,
you're,
which is in some ways indiscriminate,
indiscriminate,
indiscriminate from,
uh,
um,
well from just casual sleeping around?
Um,
I think the problem with that is that to
sleep around casually is to imply that
sex is casual.
To imply that sexist casual is to assume
implicitly that it can be divorced from
the rest of life,
emotional life,
motivational life values,
all of that.
And you can divorce it,
but you pay a big price for that.
I think the price you pay is like the
virtual,
it's,
it,
well the word psychopathic keeps
leaking,
leaping to mind,
leaking to mind.
Yeah,
good old Freud.
Um,
you have to reduce a person to the
casual pleasure of a
transients sexual interaction in order
to
sleep around casually.
And I think that once you establish that
as a habit with sex,
which is a deep,
deep experience,
if you'll,
if you'll do that with sex,
which is a deep experience then,
and you learn how,
then what makes you think that won't
transfer to everything else that you do.
I don't see how it can fail too.
So,
you know,
you could say,
well,
monogamy isn't a very good solution.
It's like,
well,
life is a fatal section.
Fatal.
What is this sexually transmitted
disease with 100% fatality rate too?
You know,
there's lots of really complex problems
for which we only have
the best answer we can come up with,
which is not,
not a utopian answer,
but I would say,
and I think the evidence supports this
as well,
that stable monogamy is the best
solution that we know of.
And it's also the minimum necessary
requirement for the stability of
children.
So
polyamory,
it's wrong,
it's wrong.
It makes men violent.
It increases inequality in,
in,
in the manner that makes things
dangerous.
It makes it impossible for women to have
a deep relationship with men.
It makes it,
it facilitates the,
uh,
what would you call it,
the transformation of sex into something
casual and then that spills out into
the,
into the rest of the world.
Um,
it deprives the people who engage in it
have the opportunity of establishing a
stable,
longterm,
mutually,
uh,
mutually satisfying.
It's more than that mutually beneficial
relationship.
You know,
cause a good,
a good marriage.
The people in it,
gay gain more than there are more than
twice as good.
Right?
It,
it,
the,
the benefits aren't precisely linear,
so you lose that destabilizes the
situation for children.
There you go,
man.
That's a lot of things that aren't about
it,
that aren't good,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
How do you think altered state of
consciousness or shamonic experiences
can you should be integrated into modern
life and scientific thought?
Man,
you guys are really asking some tough
questions today.
Well,
the first thing that we should realize
is that states of altered consciousness
are,
people have been experimenting with them
forever
and God only knows what the consequence
of this.
I certainly believe that the old Greek
mysteries were
institution induced hallucinogenic
experiences.
I think that most of the religious
stories that we have are a consequence
of psychedelic experience.
Most a substantial number of them.
It certainly seems to be the case with
so much,
for example,
which looks like it was the flyer
garrick mushroom,
the Amanita,
um,
people have been using hallucinogenics
substances for a very long time and they
produce very incomprehensible sets of
experiences,
most recently documented by the research
teams at Johns Hopkins
where they've shown that if you give
people enough magic mushrooms silicide
been to induce a mystical experience
that you decrease their death,
anxiety and fear when they have cancer
diagnosis,
which is really something.
And that a single dose of mushrooms that
produces a mystical experience has about
an 85% cure rate for smoking,
which is absolutely beyond
comprehension.
So the psychedelic substances seem to
open up another plane of so to speak.
You know,
and it's,
it's that part of experience that's,
that has an infinite scope.
Why they do that,
how they do that,
what that means.
God only knows,
God only knows.
I don't think we understand psychedelics
even a bit.
I don't think that they what?
I don't think they fit into our current
worldview.
So how should they be integrated?
Well,
you're a fool if you play with
psychedelics,
don't,
what did Carl Young say?
Beware of unearned wisdom.
That's pretty damn smart.
So you don't play with them.
If you're inclined to experiment,
then you should treat them with respect.
You should go into the experience with
the expectation and the desire that your
life will,
that you will learn something painful as
that's going to be and that your life
will be transformed in a positive
direction and you should pray to
whatever God's you worship that they
don't rip you apart.
You know?
And then maybe you'll be sensible enough
to learn something and you build to
bring it back from the underworld and
you build integrated into your life
carefully and you'll be a better person
as a consequence.
But be careful what you hope for.
Okay?
I don't even have the conscientiousness
to sit down and do self authoring.
I bought it over a year ago and haven't
opened it.
What the Hell is wrong with me?
Well,
lots of things probably because there's
lots of things wrong with everybody,
but let's,
let's not go right for the jugular.
You know,
let's assume,
let's assume that the problem is
relatively simple before we assume that
your character is beyond salvage,
which is also something I would
recommend if you're arguing with your
wife or your husband or your partner,
you know,
assume that their character can be
salvaged.
It's a good way to start the argument.
So I would say,
why don't you have a smaller goal in
also,
if you notice that you're not doing
something,
I'm not doing the self authoring
program.
Well,
maybe it's daunting to you,
you know,
or,
or maybe you're not very disciplined her
or maybe both or maybe six other things.
Who knows,
right?
Maybe you're angry that you spent money
on it.
Um,
it's,
it could be any number of reasons.
Maybe you don't want a better life.
Maybe there are things in your past you
don't want to look into.
Maybe you're afraid of your personality.
Maybe you're terrified of the future and
you don't want to think about it.
God,
any of those things can be true.
But what you want to do is first notice
that you're not doing it.
It's like,
oh,
I'm not doing this.
Well,
I must be going about it wrong.
it started the definition of wrong,
right?
If you're trying to do something and
you're not doing it,
then you're doing it wrong.
That's for sure by your own definition.
So let's say,
well,
if you're trying to do something
difficult and you're not doing it well,
you can be yourself with a stick until
you do it.
Or You could hire someone else to do it,
you know,
metaphorically speaking or even maybe
really if you want do it.
Um,
but the best,
but barring that,
the next best thing is to aim at
something lower.
Obviously your two useless to do the
self authoring program.
Okay.
Um,
ask yourself,
sit on the edge of your bed and say,
okay,
I think I'd like to try this self
authoring program.
Is there some step I could take towards
that,
that I would do?
I would say,
well,
maybe you can think what I have to do to
do it.
Oh,
I have to find my username and password.
Then I have to open the web.
No,
I've turned on my computer.
I have to look in my email.
I have to find my username and password.
I have to find the site.
I have to open the site.
Then I have to enter the username and
password and then I have to start
reading it.
Okay,
so then you think got to walk through it
like it's a simulation.
Which of those things are you unwilling
to do?
You can ask yourself,
am I willing to go turn my computer on?
Yes.
Am I willing to open my email?
Am I willing to search through my email
for the username and password?
Well,
I'm a bit worried about that because I
bought it a year ago.
I'm not sure I'm going to be able to
find the username and password.
Okay.
Do you think you can handle that
potential disappointment and
frustration?
Yes.
I could do that for 10 minutes.
Okay.
You could always buy it again,
if you look lost.
Right.
If you really want to do,
it's not that big a deal.
Okay,
so it looks like I'll turn on the
computer,
I'll sit down,
I'll turn on the computer,
open my email,
I'll look for the username and password
and I'll buy it if I can't find it.
That's possibility.
Will you actually do those things?
Like would you do them right now?
Yeah,
I think I do that.
Would you also put the username and
password into the program itself?
Well then you feel a little resistance.
You think,
well maybe,
maybe I do that.
Maybe I wouldn't.
Okay.
Would you put the username and password
into the program and start reading?
It's like,
nope,
that's too much.
It's like,
okay.
Then you might think,
well,
if I wasn't such a useless son of a
bitch,
I just sit down and do the whole thing.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe,
but you are exactly that useless kind of
son of a bitch and so you can ask
yourself politely what you're willing to
do.
You might find that you're willing to
open the damn program and put the
username and password in and like look
at the first sentence and that's a big
accomplishment.
It's like you could take yourself out
for dinner to dinner for managing that
and I'm not being cynical.
It's like way to be you opened it.
That means you have to get over your
anticipatory anxiety.
That's a big deal.
Maybe that's enough for the day.
If you're find that you're not doing
something that you know you should be
doing,
ask yourself like seriously.
Like you would ask someone else.
Like you'd ask someone you care about,
like you'd ask someone you'd listened to
what it is that you're willing to do.
You won't clean up your room.
Okay,
will you clean up your closet?
No.
Will you?
Will you look in your closet and like
think about some things that you might
clean up if you did it the next day.
It's like,
yes.
Well there you go.
Successful negotiation.
You know,
you gotta you're not your own slave and
you're not your own tyrant.
You have to deal with yourself.
You have to negotiate with yourself just
like you'd negotiate with another
person.
So that means you've got to take your
stubborn idiocy the way you find it.
You got to accept it.
And then you have to ask yourself like
you'd ask a really bratty nine year old
kid what you might be willing to do to
put another foot forward.
And then you have to do it small as it
is in humility because you're so damn
useless.
That was the best you could manage.
It's like,
well,
it's better than nothing,
so it's good enough.
And if you do that every day,
if you try that every day or every
second day or once a week for that
matter,
you know,
if you allow yourself to genuinely step
forward on a reasonably regular basis,
you'll actually move forward.
You know,
even that will do the trick because the
benefits will start to compound.
So if you're not hitting what you're
aiming at,
aim lower,
move closer to the target until you can
hit it,
until you can hit it with a little bit
of effort and accept that as your
starting point.
At least.
That's good.
You found your starting point.
Hurray.
You're on the path.
Good for you.
You know it really.
I'm serious about that.
Yeah.
My wife says,
I am like you.
I he obsessed by ideas and sell them.
Want to talk about much else she wants
me to ask if your wife has ever annoyed
by it.
Ha Ha.
No,
I don't know if she's annoyed by that.
I think she's worn out by it,
you know?
I mean,
I'm amazed that she can,
she seems to be able to live with me,
which is asking quite a lot of someone
because there's always a lot going on,
you know?
I mean,
so I don't think she's annoyed by it.
I think she's overwhelmed by it
and fair enough.
And maybe sometimes she's annoyed by it
too,
to be obsessed by ideas like that.
Well that's part of being high in trade
openness at,
especially if you're also extroverted.
That's what you like.
You know,
you're high in openness.
You should have your wife take the
understand myself,
test and,
and you two and then you can look,
we're going to build this couple's
report pretty soon.
That will,
I'm working on the paragraphs now.
The infrastructure's already in place.
That will enable people to compare one
another.
But you know,
it sounds like your extremely high in
trade.
Openness,
especially on the intellect dimension.
And perhaps your wife is lower on on
that dimension.
And so take the test and find out and
then you'll both understand that it's
characterological.
So,
okay,
you might need to find people that share
your intellectual predilection.
Um,
if you're interests are more than your
wife can easily
and happily,
let's say,
tolerate
well.
Hi Dr. Peterson.
I'm a member of the translators who
translate your video into Chinese.
How can I speak the truth and survive in
China and protect my family?
Oh Man.
While the first thing I would say is,
God,
that's a hard question.
Carefully and carefully and attentively.
How can I speak the truth and survive
carefully and attentively?
I mean,
I would say rule number one,
rule number one,
don't suck.
Don't sully your soul.
That's like rule number one in life.
You know,
you got to decide what's horrible.
And obviously being persecuted for your
opinion is horrible.
There's no doubt about that.
But being unable to,
being forced to live in a web of silence
and deception is also horrible.
I'm not going to say worse.
I'm going to say also horrible.
So you've got Hobson's choice there.
If you're going to do what you can to
tell the truth,
then do it with humility and care.
Start within the confines of your own
immediate circle.
And don't get arrogant.
Don't get arrogant,
don't think you'll get away with it.
You have to be doing it humbly and
carefully.
Okay?
Push on what you can push on that you
think might change.
And don't be contemptuous of small
victories
and take care of yourself.
Be careful.
You want to maintain yourself while
you're making your attempts so that you
can be along to around to do it for a
long time.
So see,
and I guess we could rephrase the last
part of your question because we could
also say,
how can I speak anything but the truth
and survive in China and protect my
family?
I do believe that in the medium to
longterm and all things considered,
you never have a better bet than telling
the truth.
But I do say that realizing that there
are places and times where it's
relatively safe to do so and places and
times where it's relatively unsafe to do
so.
And if you're in China now and for a
very long time,
you're in a place where it's relatively
unsafe to do so.
Don't take unnecessary risks,
dope
but don't.
But you have every reason to try to keep
your soul and your word intact.
Yeah,
my brother committed suicide and I'm
taking care of my sister's kids age
seven and three until she stables
stable.
How can I help them cope with the loss
of their uncle?
Well,
how do you help kids cope?
You
put a stable routine together around
them so that they don't have any
additional uncertainty in their life.
You decide that you're oriented towards
their future.
Good.
You know,
you got to decide that as deeply as you
can.
Are you resentful about having to take
care of them?
Cause you might be,
and maybe you have your reasons too,
but I would scour your soul for that
possibility and see if you can rectify
it by whatever means necessary,
act responsibly and reliably.
And that will give them faith in adults,
which is good because they need some
faith and they're going to be adults.
So they need to have some faith in
adults,
play with them,
pay attention to them,
play with them.
It's not a bad idea to teach kids how to
come and get a hug.
You can,
uh,
you can do that in a pretend play mode.
You know,
you say,
look,
let's practice something.
Why don't you Prac,
let's pretend that you need a hug.
And then let's pretend that you need
some practice in figuring out how to ask
for what,
because everybody needs a hug sometimes.
Even the three and the seven year old
and both should both be able to play
that game and then have them practice
until they get good at it.
And then you can play that like every
day for three weeks until they're
really,
really good at it.
And so that when they're feeling
lonesome,
they can,
and then you tell them,
look,
pretend you're feeling lonesome.
How do you come and get a hug?
And you got to figure that out.
You know,
maybe they just come on and they look at
your feet and they say,
I feeling lonesome.
I really need a hug.
And then you know,
you know,
you can teach them to come and get
attention from you when they need it.
And that's really what a kid needs is to
have someone there to pay attention when
the kid needs it.
That's really,
that's really a good thing.
The seven year old in particular is
probably going to wonder if he or she
was the cause of the suicide.
That conversation might come up.
You want it,
want to watch the kid to see if there's
any evidence that he or she believes
that
it's an easy thing for kids to believe
because it actually helps them make a
little bit of sense out of what happens.
You know,
something terrible happened.
I lost my dad.
He went away.
I wasn't good enough for them.
You know,
that's really easy,
easy thing to think.
So you might want to keep your eyes open
for the necessity of that conversation.
I'm a minority.
I kids are mixed or resent the
disempowering narrative of victim hood
being handed to them.
It's lazy and offensive.
How to arm them against it.
That's a good one.
Well,
the first question is,
you didn't tell me how old they were,
so that complicates things,
but I would say you better pay attention
to what they're being taught in school.
My suggestion to parents is that if your
kids are in a class where they talk
about diversity,
equity,
inclusivity,
gender,
white privilege,
that's not a bad,
there's other words too,
but we'll stick with those that your
kids should be encouraged to leave the
class because they're not being
educated.
They're being indoctrinated.
Now,
that doesn't mean that there can't be an
intelligent discussion about any one of
those topics,
but when they come together in a group,
then that's a pretty good marker that
you're in the vicinity of a radical
leftist,
neo Marxist ideology,
and there's no excuse for that being
foisted on your children.
You may have to have a serious chat with
your school,
with your kids,
teachers with the principal.
You may have to learn how to form your
argument,
formulate your arguments against the
practice,
like if you resent it,
what are you going to do?
You're going to put up with it.
You're going to get angry and take it
out on someone else you to do something
stupid because you're resentful.
It's like those are,
that's likely right or you're going to
swallow it and get weak.
I mean,
Jesus,
those are dismal options.
I mean,
first of all,
you might want to find out if all your
resentment is justified.
You can talk to someone that you admire
and see if you're just flying off the
handle because maybe you are.
But if you're not,
well,
if something is happening that you
really don't like,
that's a sign that you have to do
something about it because you're being
is
rebelling against that constraint.
So
you have to get more educated.
You have to get more articulate.
You have to get more politically
oriented,
politically savvy,
politically involved.
You have to talk to people and make a
coalition.
Um,
you have to face down,
you're chill,
your children's teacher.
You have to come up with a plan for what
happens if when you faced them down,
nothing changes.
You have to lay out a strategy of,
of idiation war or you have to live with
your resentment and risk.
Having your children disempowered by the
narrative of victim hood,
that seems like a really bad outcome.
You know,
if they see you resisting it actively,
then you are right then in there
acting out than the contrary narrative.
So if you don't believe that they should
be described as disempowered,
then you should act in a manner that
indicates that your convictions have far
more potency then you might believe,
okay,
Sam Harris has accused me of sophistry
and my Bible lectures.
How do you draw the line between
sophistry and a valid reading?
Well,
welcome to the universe of literary
criticism.
Seriously.
Right?
Cause that's the real question.
I look for patterns.
You know,
when I wrote maps of meaning,
which is my first book,
I laid out a description of the way that
we perceive the world and I wanted to
know if it was an accurate perception.
And so I tested it against multiple
levels of analysis and so I wanted to
see while it did it stand up,
did the story stand up logically?
Was it in keeping with the,
what was known at that point in terms of
functional neuropsychology?
Was it in keeping with the literary
tradition?
Did it make sense from the perspective
of mythology,
all of these things in my supposition
was that if
the interpretation remain coherent
across all those levels of analysis,
the probability that that was spurious
was very low.
Just like you can think about it as akin
to the way that you detect whether or
not something's real using your senses,
you have five qualitatively different
senses and if one of them reports the
existence of something that might be
faulty and if if to report the existence
of something maybe even that would be
faulty.
But if five of them report it,
then the probability that there's
something there is starting to become
high enough so that you don't die by
relying on it,
which is really our fundamental,
what would you say it?
Manifestation.
Indication of,
of sufficiency.
Um,
you know Sam's,
I don't think Sam ready accused me of
software street.
Precisely.
What he did was say like the postmodern
is say any text is susceptible,
susceptible to a very large number of
interpretations.
How do you know yours is?
While you could say true,
this is where things get complicated
because it depends on what you mean by
true,
which is another thing that Sam and I
had a head to head about.
You know,
I act out my interpretations of the
stories that I read and I detect there
the consequence of that action in the
world and use that as another means of
deep determining their validity.
So acting in this manner,
the manner that I believe is appropriate
as a consequence of the way that I've
interpreted come to interpret these
great mythological stories has been of
inestimable [inaudible] bell inestimable
benefit in my life.
And I think it's helped my family a lot,
my immediate family and my broader
family.
It's helped my friends,
it's helped my students,
it seems to be helping the broader
community and it's commensurate with
what I know scientifically.
And so
if that's sophistry that isn't sophistry
because it's just too many points of
contact.
So,
so no,
besides,
you know,
there's other ways of,
there's other ways of protecting
yourself against Sofa street to one of
the ways you can tell if you're a social
scientist and you've actually found
something is that you're not happy about
it.
So if you do a data analysis and you get
a result and you think,
Oh God,
that's the last thing I hope for,
then that's pretty good evidence.
Not Conclusive,
obviously that's pretty good evidence
that you've actually found something
real that's sorta like the data for the
data that's being generated by the
personality theorists lately showing
that as societies become more
egalitarian,
the proclivity of men and women to
choose different occupational roots
increases rather than decreases.
You can be sure that whoever made that
finding that isn't what they were hoping
for because that's,
well,
first of all,
who would hope for that?
You know,
it's,
it's just there isn't an ideology
supporting that as a desirable outcome.
I mean,
it might be a great outcome because it
means that as you make society's more
sociologically flat say in terms of
opportunity,
men and women get to choose what they
want.
And they actually choose different
things and that's okay,
you could say that,
but hardly anyone is.
So there's almost no one who's happy
when they find that.
So often when you interpret a story,
let's say you come up with a self
serving interpretation,
then you might think,
well I know I'm going to trust that
because it's self serving.
But often if you,
I believe is if you take the union tack,
for example,
through the mythological material,
you don't find what you want.
You find the opposite of that young
said,
what's his prime d dictum derive from
alchemy in sterk wiliness infinite tour,
which I'm probably butchering in terms
of pronunciation.
Of course no one knows,
uh,
cause it's Latin.
Um,
what you most want will be found where
you least want to look.
Well that's hardly a self serving
interpretation.
Who's going to generate that man?
But that's what the,
that's the dragon and the gold right
there.
So
you know,
if your interpretation makes things more
difficult for you,
it makes things more challenging,
requires you to be more mature,
requires you to be more responsible.
All of those things.
Then I would also say that that's a
testament to its validity because it's
not self evidently contaminated by
impulsive self interest.
So
how is it that society has not learned
from history about the dangers of
socialism,
Marxism,
radiology,
et Cetera,
after years,
how to Marxists get away with it?
Well,
let's,
let's not go with the dangers of
etiology.
Let's go with the dangers of like to
call it radical left wing ideology.
Well,
I think the reason for this,
and this also might buy the reason,
be the reason that there's a strange
thing that the iconography of,
of social of communism is still
acceptable socially,
whereas the iconography of Nazi-ism
isn't.
Now,
I'm not saying that we should make the
icons of Nazi-ism socially acceptable
either.
I think that the communist icon
shouldn't be socially acceptable,
but they are.
And there's probably a reason for that.
You know,
now part of it is that the left has
never taken on.
The radical left has ne never taken
responsibility for being on the same
side as the Stalinists and the Maoists
and the Cambodian murderers and all of
that.
So that's part of it.
But then the next part is,
I think there's something deeper.
I think that
no inequality is a reality and it's a
reality that cannot be put at the feet
of capitalism or at the feet of human
political structure.
There's a good book you guys might want
to read this called the great leveler by
Walter Shy Dale,
and it's a new book and it's the study
of inequality.
And one of the things he does is do an
empirical analysis of the relationship
between inequality,
the Gini Coefficient,
which is a measure of inequality and the
ideological position of governments.
So here's the theory.
The hypothesis would be,
well,
because the left wingers are concerned
with inequality,
if you measured inequality in left wing
under left wing governments and you
measured inequality under right wing
governments,
you'd expect a reduction in inequality
under left wing governments.
And the results are
no difference.
And so what does that mean?
It doesn't mean that left wings are
hypocrites,
although it might mean that because
people can be hypocrites.
But what it means is the problem of
inequality is so intractable that we
don't know of any appropriate
political sociological or economic
solutions that actually work.
It's a real catastrophe.
Now,
inequality in itself might not be a bad
thing unless it's too extreme.
It's extreme.
When people say start to starve and then
clearly somethings you know it's,
it's very difficult to,
I think everyone would agree that that's
a suboptimal outcome.
You know,
we don't need to get all the ideological
about that,
but some degree of inequality is useful
because well it gives people something
to strive for.
It gives them an op,
right?
It means,
I was thinking about this sometimes you
actually want people to be rich because
if a new product is introduced into the
market,
the people there have to be people
around who have substantial pools of
capital to be able to afford it when
it's still novel and then that market
brings the price down for everyone else.
And so if everyone had exactly the same
income,
it would be very difficult to introduce
expensive products into the market with
the hope that their price would plummet.
Not actually is a big deal.
You want large pools of capital sitting
around too so that people can invest in
very,
very complex things.
And you also want large pools of capital
would be the hands have to be in the
hands of private individuals so that
there's competitive,
there's forces that are powerful,
that are competitive with the government
and with other large organizations.
So anyways though back to the Marxists,
despite the fact that there are reasons
for inequality and despite the fact that
you can't lay the fact of inequality at
the feet of capitalism and despite the
fact that capitalism also appears to be
making everyone not absolutely poor at
the same time as it makes some people
very rich,
there's still inequality is still
painful reality and no one really likes
it.
You know?
I mean you can lord it over someone I
suppose and and extract out some sense
of your moral superiority because you
happen to occupy a hierarchical position
that's higher and sometimes there's some
validity in that,
especially if you've earned it.
Although I would say like glorying in it
is probably a suboptimal outcome.
It's still the case that that violates a
moral intuition that everyone has.
I think,
and that's probably the moral intuitions
that lie along the agreeable access.
It's like,
well,
wouldn't it be better if everyone had
enough?
It's like,
well,
who argues with that?
You know,
I mean everyone feels that way.
And so I think,
um,
a thoughtless,
a thoughtless compassion makes Marxism
naively attractive.
And I'm not being cynical about that
because there is some utility in naive
agreeableness,
but unfortunately the world is a very
complicated place and merely wanting to
be nice about things and wishing that
everything was fair doesn't justify
imposing an equity outcome and
Gerrymandering,
complex economic systems that will bite
you if you mess with them because your
idiot logically possessed.
I am 46 retired executive,
wealthy,
competent and full of juice.
Who could I talk to if I want to invest
time slash money slash energy in your
university
people,
lots of people are,
are asking me such things and it's very
much appreciated.
It's a weird,
you know,
because you'd think that if people are
offering you time and money that it
would be a straight forward thing to
say,
yes,
please climb aboard and help.
But it's not that simple because first
of all,
I don't want to involve people in
something that I can't be sufficiently
committed to.
It's not fair to them.
Um,
and it isn't obvious to me how I can be
committed to this yet fully committed to
it.
And so I'm sort of playing with it at
the level that I can manage.
It's not like it's a game.
We have a good product in involved or a
good product in,
in motion at the moment.
But I'm not,
I don't have the wherewithal to scale at
the moment.
And you know,
you can say,
and people who are developing new
businesses like to do this.
Like let's say I could come up with a
draft business plan for an online
university and then I can contact people
like you Paul and say,
look,
I'm ready to gather investments and
let's say I could raise $20 million or
let's say I could raise $200 million,
but then I have a new problem.
The problem is,
well all my God,
I've got all this money,
now I have to figure out something to do
with it.
And that's actually a really big
responsibility.
Not Start like,
you know,
it's a success catastrophe.
Let's say it's a first world problem.
I get all that,
but that doesn't mean that it isn't
real.
So I have to do a lot more thinking and
planning
and figure out how to disperse my time
most effectively before I dare to take
on any additional people who would like
to help.
Now,
once my organization as it is in a place
where that sort of help would be useful,
then I'll make a public announcement and
I would be more than happy for people to
jump on board.
Let's say climb on board,
start pushing,
devote resources,
all of those things.
I'd be happy for that to happen then,
but I don't want to do it prematurely
because I don't want people to,
to risk their valuable resources in an
endeavor that isn't yet solid.
So,
all right,
so I'm only going to do,
I think one more question.
Um,
okay.
I am a sober alcoholic slash drug
addict.
How can I find my way back to belief in
a higher power after 10 years in the
empty void of atheism?
I'm falling apart.
Well,
I would say your best bet is to actually
start devoting some,
some time to it.
You know,
for me,
I became convinced of the validity of a
religious viewpoint.
I think as a consequence of study
read,
Joseph Campbell read Carl Young Young's
hard.
Campbell's a good introduction though.
Richa Ellie Outta as well.
I don't know if you can find your way
back to belief,
but you might be able to find your way
back to meaningful engagement and that
might,
that's a better way of thinking about
it.
You know,
the belief thing is a really tricky one.
People ask me,
do you believe in God?
And I think,
I really think,
how dare you ask that question.
I think that's really what I think,
but on a more prosaic level,
I usually think,
well,
I don't know what you mean by belief.
I don't know what you mean by belief and
I don't know what you mean by God.
These are very,
these are very difficult questions and
none of that self evident.
Now I would say,
do I believe in the crucifixion?
Well,
certainly,
I mean people,
the crucifixion,
how can you not believe in it if you
think symbolically,
it's like human beings are,
we're eternally crucified,
right?
Our lives are tragic and they end in
death and were,
were all betrayed.
We're all betrayed.
We all experienced betrayal.
So you can't not believe the
crucifixion.
Do you believe in the resurrection?
Well,
people die and are reborn all the time.
You know,
they,
they go through,
this is what you're after here.
I'm a sober drug and alcohol drug
addict.
Well,
you know,
you,
you had to let a lot of you die when you
stop being an addict and something new
be reborn.
It's like what's the ultimate
significance of that and how is it tied
to the notion of bodily resurrection?
Well,
I don't know what the ultimate
significance is,
but it does seem to be the pathway
through life
to believe.
I would say you start believing not by
attempting to
convince yourself that the statement
there is a god is true,
like a fact is true,
but to act out the proposition that you
should shoulder your cross and stumble
uphill towards the city of God.
That's belief,
man.
Yeah,
and you can do that.
right away.
Okay.
Now you might ask,
well,
do I have any guarantee that that has
transcendent and universal significance?
It's like,
well,
it's not a bad model for emulation,
so it has universal significance in that
regard.
We each have to shoulder the tragedy of
our existence and stumble upwards.
Despite that that has universal
significance.
Does it have significance outside of
life and like get the internal eternal
realm?
I wouldn't surprise me if it did.
I suppose it depends on what you mean by
the eternal realm.
The
seems to have significance in the
eternal realm of consciousness.
It seems to have significance in the
eternal realm of unconscious fantasy,
implicit fantasy and mythology.
How is it connected with the factual
world?
Yeah,
that's a hard question because the
factual world in some sense divorced
itself from that transcendental world
during the development of the scientific
methodology,
so never the twain shall meet.
It's a methodological issue in part
I think you probably have to draw on the
same forces that enabled you to sober up
and abandoned your drug addiction.
No,
something was guiding you forward.
Go forward again,
go forward again as if there there is a
higher power.
That's your manifestation of faith.
Go forward again as if being is
benevolent and God is good.
That's the hallmark of courage
and that's good place to stop.
Thank you all for showing up today and,
uh,
and for all the support and,
and that's enough for March,
March 4th,
2018 bye bye.
Okay.